it's a case that for the last eight
years has reverberated across Mexico
on a rainy night in the country's
Southwest 43 students were hauled off
buses taken away and never seen again
this man the then attorney general said
a gang killed them in League with local
police he called that the historical
truth it wasn't
startling irregularities were soon found
in the investigation top officials
suspected of involvement remained
untouched Mexican impunity had
apparently struck again
the students parents and tens of
thousands of others marched out raced
but the case still went nowhere now is
the anniversary of the disappearances
comes around again things seem to
finally be moving
for the first time this past August a
government-backed truth commission said
this was a crime of the state with
military police and government officials
all involved in the disappearances
the ex-attorney general Zeus Maria Quran
was arrested put in prison in his
waiting trial those campaigning for
justice hope it's just the start
he's a high-level official but in the
end we know who was responsible for this
which in this case was former president
Enrique Pena Nieto
opinioneto's not been charged but his
administration has been accused by
investigators of a cover-up
then this month for former Army General
was arrested Mexico's human rights under
secretary said that he allegedly oversaw
The Killing and disappearance of the
bodies of six students that's huge the
Army's long thought to have been
involved in the crime but before it
seemed untouchable
now the question is how much further is
the government willing to go public
prosecutors have issued arrest warrants
for 44 police officers and in total 20
military personnel in connection to the
case will those warrants be served a lot
depends on that especially as the Army
is a strong Ally of the current Mexican
president Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
what's happened in previous
administrations in cases like this one
is that they've arrested a couple of
former officials but it's been more
political posturing Point scoring than
an attempt to really get to the bottom
of things and that's what the people who
are camped here outside of the old
attorney general's building together
with these posters of the Disappeared
students are hoping will be different
this time that there will be a real
attempt to get Justice
the test of this government's commitment
to justice is just beginning officials
have the arrest warrants will they
finish what they started John Holman Al
Jazeera Mexico City